namely Thomas Middleditch
listen listen since I've met you I've
nearly been incinerated drowned shot at
chopped into fish bait we're caught in
the middle of something sinister here
my guess is dad found out more than he
was looking for until I'm sure I'm going
to continue to do the things they'll do
things the way I think they should be
done
[Applause]
yeah I know I know
name please my name I'm Billy Eichner
what is this India and they're remaking
Indiana Jones why so what's he gonna be
by now it woke leave me alone I don't
like fast women I don't like women name
please
sandwiches you know what idea I had just
reimagining that maybe this this time he
loves snicks he makes no my snakes from
home do you have anybody play the kid
the kid from Temple of Doom a short
round thinking I can do a pretty good
Asian accent oh please don't
it's pretty good it's pretty funny and
finally we're good think so it's I think
I'll do it anyway Indiana Jones
that's that's too much yeah what's back
no you know what I gotta take more out
this is this seems good you don't have
to be exact
no it does need to be exact it's
actually very precise
I mean I I don't know about you but I
don't want a boulder rolling in here and
killing all of us so if you don't mind
I'm gonna take a little more time with
this is that is that okay with you see
what did I tell you you know what this
is mine separate how are you he's good
said there's the only guy for the row
TIG Notaro oh no a giant boulder
[Applause]
mr. Kevin Sedgwick six four so let's see
it I was an animal house with Karen
Allen who was in Raiders of the Lost Ark
sorry what are you doing oh I'm sorry I
was just saying how many degrees of
separation I am from Indiana Jones it's
two I was in murder in the first william
h Macy William H Macy was in Air Force
one with Harrison Ford V Harrison Ford
who is Indiana Jones so that's three I
can do this all day
really but there's also the option of
you know so if they're doing sidekicks
right mm-hmm yeah I've been working on
this character's name Smitty zoom in and
you wants to come at the end right and
you know they're lifting up the lid and
it's like don't look and Smitty's kind
of like well yeah it's you're gonna
Covenant deal with it okay thank you
well thank you Thomas okay I thought it
was a Don Cheadle no everybody thinks
something and then they get corrected
damn Jada
does he have lasers that shoot out of
his chest or not traditionally you know
what let's let's add that throw that in
I'll pay for it
see the sound effect me just put those
in over this for free yeah
sorry what are you doing what did you
see the movie yeah okay Boulder giant
boulder that giant boulder on your eyes
giant boulder
[Applause]